monsieur bonjour les premiers étaient
arrivés tranquillement dans l'après midi
cette nuit les rêveurs était plus de
10000 sur le site de la prévalaye à
rennes une grosse affluence comme prévu
mais pas d'incident
la rave placé sous haute surveillance a
démarré dans un bon esprit comme l'ont
constaté stéphane grammont et thierry
bouyer le quartier de la prévalaye ne
s'est pas endormi tranquille mais avec
de bonnes boules quies la nuit pourra
être correct à quelques centaines de
mètres le son monte en puissance
progressivement on vient du grand ouest
du loir-et-cher de la creuse bref de
partout aux abords de la teuf on n'est
pas dupe il y adeux l'ado des drogues
dures 12 de l'alcool sur cinq stands
différents des associations ne sont pas
là pour juger mais pour accompagner et
sensibiliser aux risques pour l'heure à
penser éventuellement d'instruction
autour de ça réfléchir mais pourquoi est
ce que la sexualité
zermatt if fait réfléchir à ce que ça
peut entrer en termes de responsabilité
vous invite à partenaires c'est la même
chose sur le tabac sur l'alcool rossi
ont passé un moment coeur de la nuit les
sens presque tous installés des murs
d'enceinte des dj des sonorités aux tic
arous tardinghen chacun respecte donc
sondé temps de répondre à la presse
massée dans une très bonne ambiance et
comprend très bien les autres en fait
danser des acteurs leur fait la
convivialité sont des global l'état
comme ils disent les zones d'autonomie
temporaire pour leur code de bonne
conduite
les gens c'est de prendre conscience
vont mener des sacs qu'il faut ramasser
au minimum ou moins ces saloperies et
puis si ce monde venant sans cela je
pense que dans quelques années ça va
être parfait quoi au coeur de la nuit
les errements pour la désignation d'un
terrain était oublié les jeunes les
dégâts tous ont conscience qu'ils
existeront malgré l'esprit bonne
conduite afficher désormais chacun est
dans son monde
c'est parti pour trois nuits et deux
jours de trois ans elle aussi malgré
tout musical